days of monsoon rains and rivers are
bursting their banks in parts of
Northern India
leaving temples like this submerged
[Music]
comes back to the temple and other small
temples are under river water the
situation is very bad it's been raining
heavily for the past 12 to 14 hours in
Kulu and Mandi districts as you can see
the Bears Rivers overflowing punch back
to the temple which is a tourist spot
right it's a waterlogged and public
buildings have been forced to close more
rains expected and meteorologists are
warning people in the worst affected
areas
a red alert has been issued in Himachal
Pradesh many districts are witnessing
heavy rainfall orange and yellow alerts
have also been issued in other districts
due to the Rain
these people are forced to travel on
foot after rock falls and landslides
block the road to the hillside town of
Shimla but despite the flooding many
people are trying to keep their
businesses going
the condition is very bad in gurugram I
took a customer to the border and my
Elixir got fully submerged in water over
there three other vehicles got submerged
as well
the monsoon season almost always leads
to properties being damaged
urban planners say Construction in
wetlands and clogged drainage systems
are partly to blame for the for the
chaos in the cities
Barbara angopa Al Jazeera